voici troubadours ce fameux fichier
constitué entre avril et septembre 2001
par la police municipale d'albertville
par discrétion certaines informations
sont cachés mais dans la colonne de
droite apparaissent très nettement les
mentions homo ou maghrébins des méthodes
qui très vite surprennent et choquent
les agents mon équipe dirigée par
l'adjoint du chef de police équipées
mission que te donner part parce
personne
effectivement il eu des dérapages de
leur combat le public nous a demandé de
sortir des personnes après les abysses
pandémique de l'industrie puis d'or ne
saisie informatique sur les dimensions
mouscron piercing est libre fin août
2001 lorsqu'il découvre l'existence de
ce fichier le commandant du détachement
local de la police nationale alerte le
maire qui ordonne la suppression du
fameux fichier sans pour autant prévenir
le parquet un comportement qui étonne le
syndicat cfdt qui lui réclame
immédiatement l'ouverture d'une enquête
judiciaire
pourquoi un moment donné la mairie
d'albertville n'a pas informé le parquet
lorsqu'elle a eu connaissance de ce
fichier pourquoi la mairie d'albertville
n'a pas sanctionné le responsable de ce
fichier au lieu de le sanctionner il
était promu au grade supérieur et à
l'échelon supérieur
pour toute réponse à notre demande
d'interview le maire albert gibello
publie ce simple communiqué où il
affirme avoir mis fin à ces pratiques
mais où il s'interroge sur les
fondements de la démarche de l'udps et
cfdt
un an après les faits reste que la loi
prévoit cinq ans d'emprisonnement et
plus de 300000 euros damende pour tous
les responsables de ce genre de
pratiques qui menace gravement les
libertés individuelles